all right so as we speak the house of
representatives now pouring through
49 brand new additional pages of newly
uncovered text messages between peter
strzok and lisa page now you might
remember
these messages were a part of the six
months of
missing texts that somehow well were
lost because of an alleged technical
issue
with the fbi issued samsung phones fox
news can right now confirm
that many of these unearthed texts
contain incomplete information
and some are totally incomprehensible
sarah carter joins us in a few minutes
with the brand new information
and of course we know in previous texts
peter struck lisa page
constantly trashing president trump
calling him an idiot a menace a lonesome
human being
and even said f trump and prior to
election day in 2016 peter strzok also
mentioned
some kind of insurance policy that was
proposed to andrew mccabe
if trump should assume office now
quote i want to believe the path that
you threw out for consideration in
andy's office that there's no way he
gets elected
but i'm afraid we can't take that risk
it's like an insurance policy
in the unlikely event you die before
you're 40.
what did that mean also remember the
letter from
then senator harry reid urging jim comey
to open up a trump russia collusion
investigation into president trump
after that letter became public peter
strzok well he texted lisa page
a link to a new york times article
referencing the letter writing quote
here we go now we're literally just
actively
they were actively rooting for the
president's demise or
what is the insurance policy what is the
insurance plan was it to drag the
president through the mud
either way it's not a good look for two
people
that were tapped by robert mueller for
key roles in the special counsel
investigation witch hunt
and even worse this does critical damage
to the reputation
of our system of justice every one of us
every american
needs to be concerned all right also
breaking tonight james comey
was grilled by brett bear right here on
the fox news channel
he's now claiming that the clinton
bought and paid for
unverified uncorroborated dossier that
made up
the bulk of the pfizer application he's
saying did not make up the bulk of the
fisa information against the trump
campaign associate
even though we have two congressional
memos that contradict
what james comey said just a few minutes
ago well a few hours ago take a look
you called the dossier unverified
salacious
why did you use that to the fisa court
to ask for surveillance for
carter page not only used it but you led
with it
a bulk of that fisa application deals
with that dossier
why yeah that's not my recollection
brett and i don't know that the fisa
application has been released my
recollection was it was part of
a broader mosaic of facts that were laid
before the fisa judge to obtain a
fisa warrant it was a lot more than the
dossier in the fisa application my
recollection was there was a significant
amount of additional material about
paige and why there was probable cause
to believe he was an agent of a foreign
power and the dossier
was part of that but was not all of it
or a critical part of it
my recollection i'm having a really hard
time believing that
and this is almost unbelievable jim
comey still claiming
not to know who paid for hillary's
dirty dossier with russian lies and
propaganda
that was put together by a foreign
national including russian government
lies
look at this when did you learn that the
dnc and hillary clinton campaign had
funded christopher steele's work yeah i
still don't know that for a fact
what do you mean i've only seen it in
the media i never knew exactly which
democrats had funded
i knew it was funded first by
republicans opposed to donald trump
i'm sorry that's not true that the
dossier that christopher steele worked
on was funded by republicans my
understanding was his work started
funded by oppo as oppo research funded
by republicans
so free beacon uh and said that they had
glenn simpson and fusion gps on a kind
of a
retainer but they did not fund the
christopher steele
memo or the dossier that was initiated
by democrats
okay my understanding was the activity
was begun that
steel was hired to look into was first
funded
by republicans then picked up the
important thing was picked up by
democrats opposed to donald trump
this is mind-blowing they never verified
it
he didn't know who funded it really and
christopher steele was not brought in
until
hillary took over the fusion gps deep
dive into donald trump
now earlier today the president called
in to fox and friends and
sounded off rightly so on jim comey
listen to the president
comey is a leaker and he's a liar
and not only on this stuff he's been
leaking for years
he's probably been using his friend the
so-called professor who now turns out to
have
fbi at clearance which he never said he
even lied about that because
he never said that in congress he said
he gave it to a friend
and he gave it to a friend to leak
classified
information it's all classified it was
totally classified
so he illegally he did an illegal act
and he said it himself in order to get a
special counsel
against me so the special counsel and by
the way
and intelligence committee and everybody
else has found no collusion
nobody unclassified them and those memos
were about me and their phony memos
he didn't write those memos accurately
he put a lot of phony stuff
president's correct and the president
also slamming the department of justice
and mueller's partisan witch hunt let's
take a look at this
i answer this all the time because of
the fact
that they have this witch hunt going on
with people in the justice department
that shouldn't be there
they have a witch hunt against the
president of the united states going on
i've taken the position and i don't have
to take this position and maybe i'll
change
that i will not be involved with the
justice department
i will wait till this is over it's a
total
uh it's all lies and it's a horrible
thing that's going on so i'm very
disappointed in my justice department
but because of the fact that it's going
on and i think you'll understand this
i have decided that i won't be involved
i may change my mind at some point
because what's going on is a disgrace
it's an absolute disgrace and and by the
way
the only collusion is the collusion with
the democrats and the russians you take
a look at what's going on there
they wouldn't even give their server the
dnc
democratic national committee wouldn't
even give its server to the fbi
so what kind of an fbi they break down
doors
for paul manafort early in the morning
his wife is in bed
like at five or six in the morning and
they
they undo the lock for michael cohen
early in the morning
and yet they walk into the dnc and they
won't give them the server they say
we're not giving you the server oh okay
we'll leave that's not the fbi that's a
fix
why didn't they demand those dnc servers
a phenomenal point double standard
president trump is right
now earlier today the national reviews
victor davis hanson
an incredible column breaking down the
shocking double standard in very clear
terms
mueller was all too happy to target
former national security adviser michael
flynn
35 years of service to his country for
lying to the fbi the fbi agents
interview him
interviewing him didn't think so andrew
mccabe he remains uncharged
even after the inspector general report
reported multiple lies
to federal investigators under oath and
james comey
also remains free and clear when he lied
to congress about not writing hillary
clinton's exoneration letter
before investigating and interviewing
clinton and then peter strzok
interviewed clinton what about james
clapper we know he lied
under oath about data collection on
americans
and john brennan who lied under oath
about the dirty dossier
and then of course no charges as the
president was just saying
for cheryl mills who misled
investigators about
hillary clinton's private server or huma
abedin
who also tried to conceal hillary's
illicit server
then there's the obstruction of justice
charges that mueller is all too happy to
investigate
as long as it's donald trump or somebody
related to trump but not james comey
who clearly misled a fisa judge
about the clinton bought and paid for
foreign dossier put together by
christopher steele
in order to obtain a warrant against the
trump campaign associate
an opposition party before the election
seriously is this the united states or
we venezuela
now the clinton campaign they paid this
former spy
a foreign national to write the dossier
using russia propaganda and lies
nobody verified it or corroborated it
and they still presented it to a fisa
judge
and they omitted who paid for it not
clinton associates cheryl mills
she claimed attorney-client privilege in
order to get out of testifying
during the server investigation and now
the newest edition of president trump's
legal
team former new york city mayor rudy
giuliani
he is weighing in on the ongoing mueller
witch hunt
telling a local news station quote i can
guarantee you this
when mueller is finished no matter
whatever he does
he's not going to have a stitch of
evidence that meaning he
president trump colluded with the
russians now that's a disgrace
the case should be over the mayor's
right now even the attorney general
finally jeff sessions is calling
for the mueller probe to come to an end
for the sake of this country
this needs to come to an end watch this
i think the american people are
concerned
and the president is concerned he's
dealing with
france and north korea and syria and
taxes and regulations and
border and crime uh every day
and i wish this this thing needs to
conclude it needs to conclude yes sir mr
attorney general
he also claimed that he would not be
appointing a second special counsel to
investigate
deep state crimes because special
counsel investigations take on a life of
their own
well you don't say take a look we're
determined
to be disciplined stay within our
classical procedures and rules
i do not think we need to willy-nilly
appoint special counsels uh
and um as we can see it can
it can really take on a life of its own
let me be clear these are obvious
examples of bias
that's a bias at some of the highest
levels of our system of justice in this
country
every american you should be troubled i
always say let not your heart be
troubled
but this is an obvious two-tiered system
of justice
we all deserve and must demand better
and by the way we'll have more analysis
on the steep state corruption later in
the show but first
now despite pressure from some of his
liberal hollywood friends kanye west
good for him he's not backing down from
his quote
love for president trump and kanye was
pictured leaving his studio proudly
wearing his
make america great again hat and earlier
today tweeted quote
if you feel something don't let peer
pressure manipulate you
i love people that stand up for what
they believe in anyway this week kanye
west
he's been taking a stand for individual
thought after supporting
black conservative candace owens who
came under fire from the left for
comments about
victim mentality culture by the way
we'll have more on kanye's developing
friendship with the president later in
the program condos also is going to be
on the show tonight